[Music]
hey welcome back I'm Jesse I'm here at
the Wolfram tech conference talking with
various developers and interesting
people using our technology I'm here
right now with Christians who's gonna
tell us a little bit about what he does
at the company and sort of what his
focus is on sure thanks yes yes I'm
Christy I'm Christopher scale from the
world from research South America team
so my team works primarily on connecting
the wharf land Wolfram language to
external services to make the eyes and
now we're focusing a lot on blockchain
stuff so we have the love develop a lot
of very nice functionalities like
Wikipedia data that's a good one like
what image search send message I like
that one site can send stuff to my cell
phone I actually used that that send
mail functionality as well the send
message
and well and now we are developing all
these blockchain functionalities so you
can read in the next release you you'll
be able to also write to block chains
and there's also a lot of educational
background for these not only for our
users but also for for us because we use
our own technology to learn about these
love ginseng to develop before we get
into a sort of educational background
that can you okay I know too much about
blockchain so can you explain it to me
like I'm five like what is a blockchain
how does it really tell like Bitcoin in
etherium just you know for me and also
that that's a funny question because I
don't I'll be lying if I say there's a
unique answer but so I could say like
blockchain is a decentralized technology
but that's not completely true because
you can also find some block chains that
are like partially centralized but I
would say it's a new type of network
architecture at least with one of the
goals I guess G at least partially
decentralized or at least not to have
like a main agent in this in the system
controlling everything so and out like
Bitcoin and aetherium relate to that so
Bitcoin was the first blockchain and
uninsured so we don't know who invented
Bitcoin right I don't know if
this I guess is a human we made them
these or group of humans
whatever this Satoshi person can in in
mine also are using these these
technology for more things and what
beacon is actually used for that is
basically a detour currency system it's
very limited but it's intentionally
limited because you just wanted to work
in some certain ways so like the
language behind bitcoin is not even
Turing complete which is good because it
makes the network work better and so
yeah so so so blockchain is I'll say
let's try to think about it as a new
type of network architecture where do
you have a lot of participants there and
you are not only using the network but
you are also being part I've been an
active part of the network like a lot of
these agents in the case of VidCon for
example that we call them nodes they are
contributing to the
to the network like in the case of
beacon they are mining going to to
validate transactions and make the
network function properly if theorem
case so it's a more general application
of this technology because in the case
of the theorem is that's actually during
covet language that took the idea behind
bitten that is the launching technology
and actually so if you read the beacon
white paper there's no mention of a
blockchain so there's one part it says
chain of blocks I believe but there's no
actual word for blockchain and I'm
trying to find where that war came from
so I'm still looking for that I I
haven't found it like the first time the
blockchain is I said when full war was
used but there are references to get to
the chain of logs in the white paper or
maybe even like blog space chain but yes
also so like in the case of Kieran they
take this basic concept of the
centralized network and expanded and
expanded that to Turing complete
language and they made this
decentralized network
to support what they're called
decentralized apps so those are apps
that work on this issue into lines
network but there are a lot of different
types of blockchain so I think we are
like in the if you think about the
internet we are like in the 90s of the
Internet okay so it's still like and
kind of like embryonic yeah so so
there's still no I believe there's still
no definitive answer to what blockchain
is but at least and one of the things we
want to wit with world languages to
provide tools to understand these types
of block chains and maybe when they come
up with a definite answer no no no I
so right now well from language just
connects to whatever existing block
chains so we are currently supporting
the Bitcoin and human blockchain so like
we work out on making these
functionalities
have like nice names that communicate
what we are doing and for example what I
can say I can get information from say
the Bitcoin blockchain I'm gonna get
basic information from this I can also
do that with the etherion blockchain and
one very cool team we're we are doing is
that and not a lot of people can do this
he said we're also connected to the test
nets of these blog chains because no
when you want to when you want to say
play with do some experiments on these
blog chains if you are gonna do this
with real bitcoins you probably probably
lose your all your money if you work and
assessment you can do all sort of great
experiments with basically fake money so
we are also connected to to the Bitcoin
and if you're in testing it and ADHD so
this is these are just very basic
functions to get information about the
current status of the network but I can
go even deeper like I can ask for let's
say let's take the last block of the
Bitcoin blockchain
and this is super useful I think because
not only like do you show up our
technology but to understand what's
happening behind this these networks so
you can go even deeper and like to get
transactions we are in the next release
we are including even more
functionalities like distract tokens
which which is like the type of
structure in the theorem Network I have
just care about a group the kiddies know
so it's okay tell me about it what is it
so actually I didn't like I didn't know
like too much about this but it's a
decentralized app where you can buy
these unique kiddies and while their
crypto kitties and can you guess what
their properties are they are called
contributes can't review catching yeah
so when do we have is that we are going
to launch one one app for four dogs
since and the architecture is going to
be called AB architecture yeah so anyway
so these the cistern the centralized app
I think it was released last year I
think and and and it caused a huge
congestion in the human network because
everyone was buying these cryptic IDs
you have to buy them with with eater
which is the native I feel
currency and and and and token is
basically assigning like creating
sending value to something like in the
real world and it is a doesn't have to
be like a real thing there are different
types of tokens so like in today's
technology you can do something like by
a trip to Acapulco with house of horrors
because you're like making these
abstractions of the concept of value and
make converting them in these scripted
tokens so yes so this cryptic Keating's
game has these units which are unique
and well that's true that's very true
and yeah it's got reflecting their
reality so you can combine these crypto
kiddies and like produce new ones with
different attributes I think it's not so
different from like a card trading game
I haven't played myself like I can work
with data from the cryptic it is a game
as I don't own a crypto theory but one
of the guys in our team they have a
kitty because we are buying one one of
those to experiment with our technology
and improved achilles so so anyway so
currently where we are connecting to
those two block chains but we have
developed all this nice architecture of
our own notes
on our own internal API that is flexible
enough to support other blog chains so
the idea is that in the future will be
supporting connections to order block
chains and we are actually talking very
often to different block chaining
cryptocurrency companies who want to
like work with us and and that's going
to be great and again it's not only
great for users it's also great for us
because that like the cycle of
supporting this technology starts with
studying and researching this this block
chain so like when we had to connect to
the Bitcoin blockchain we also had to
study a lot about how this works so we
we use our own technology to play with
this blockchain and understand all the
technology behind it and we are
expecting our users to use to use that
as well to learn about this technology
we are also planning to release a lot of
educational videos
you know under wolfram view platform so
yes like for example I have here this is
a computation computational essay I
wrote about a like the most common type
of Bitcoin transaction you can have like
different types of transaction but this
is when you like when you buy something
with Bitcoin or you use send me because
what's happening in the blockchain is
usually something like this so our
language is very cool here to not only
make all these things happen but also to
explain what's happening here
yeah you can see like you can see here
for example the like the scripts running
on the blockchain and all these small
details and we also are developing a lot
of cryptographic functions we are we
already had trigger graphic functions
but now we are adding we are supporting
this technology the block chains use and
importantly we have like very smart
people working in these so
you can like you can find on the
internet a lot of now blockchain or
let's say you if you Google I know
becoming this or become basics or
whatever is this would this be a Bitcoin
for dummies well I'm I'm dumb enough to
understand it so so you can find a lot
of very very good like videos on YouTube
explaining oldies but their limitations
are that a lot of those videos which are
again they're very good they use for
example a whiteboard or yeah we're a
PowerPoint presentation where you see
the code stuff like that but here you
can actually run the code and you can
play with that and you can interact so
you don't want to waste your money so
you can interact with the facility
between tests nope I think I'm using a
bit contestant here right and personally
like I I like live coding stuff so so
yeah it's actually pretty cool too let's
say for example I don't know so we had
this thing here from the
your blockchain so let's say let's look
up these paints
so this these are just some theorem
stats for the network but yet to show
you an example
let's try something like these
so I don't know I can get like a nice
lease plot from these stats real week
and and I think that makes the audience
get like more engaged with what you're
doing because they are actually seeing
you writing these and probably the most
exciting part is when you you write
something wrong and everything breaks I
think that's what the audience is
expecting oh yeah it's like NASCAR they
only watch yeah yeah yeah that's a fun
part so but also that's another cool
part of our language that if you mess up
something
it's intuitive enough so you can fix
that it's super where do you I guess see
this sort of technology with Bob change
like going in the next so I see I guess
at least two different prawns one is
more like in the data science part and
actually maybe three so from from one
side you have access to all these data
from the blog chains eventually like a
lot of more blog chain so you can read
data from from from those and
you know and use all our computational
power and that and also there's this
part so we have all these API related
functions which are I think super useful
for like app developers so you can let's
let's try can I try something yeah let's
do it
so let's say for example so we have the
API function here try block variable so
what we are doing here is I'm I'm
getting on just one block from the let's
use of beat the blockchain
so I'm going to tell the language okay
so keep me use a Bitcoin maenette and
extract from here the the byte count
that's the size of a block we're going
to convert these a string I hope this
works well that's that exciting part of
life Bodi right so let's say going to
make an API to get the the size of the
block so I will say for example
[Music]
let's try to so these are bytes okay so
we are going to deploy this to our cloud
or use the cloud below it function let's
just call this API make this available
for everyone well let's see if this
works so like if I open my terminal here
and I can curl so I'm not using water
language anymore I'm using standard Curl
Curl function basically in any
programming language can support this so
you could you could be doing this from
Python or whatever let's say I don't
know this block
yep so I get the result here Oh awesome
yeah and I shall let's try something I
don't know if this is gonna work yeah
let's try something a little more
complex maybe it'll crash maybe yeah so
let's say and this is this is an
opportunity to show one of our functions
so let's try the text translation
function let's say the unity know how to
speak Italian okay there's some problem
because we have this we have a lot of
Italian so we should ask them is this a
correct translation but I believe this
is a correct translation so let's say
you don't know how to speak Italian so
we are going to make this API translate
this into Italian and let's try again oh
yeah yeah the result in Italian so okay
just mine so yeah so that's this is I
think very very useful like you find if
I'm an app developer I'm probably
developing in in in other language like
I don't like Swift or Java or whatever
but I can make all my back in working
with these functions that are like I
don't know we took us like one minute
API it's super powerful
so yeah that's another interesting part
of our technology and another very
important part is what I was talking
about before it is the educational part
so using all these to teach other people
about these technologies
and for them to use our language to keep
exploring the topics
that's everything by themselves and
again we have the test it's connected to
the language so they don't have to waste
their money
[Music]